meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die treue zum bau eines kanals wissen
dass man kanal nicht nur aushilfen
übrigens besteht zu 90 prozent schon
aber nicht ganz und genau aus diesem
grund für mehr abwechslung auf diesem
kanal begeben wir uns heute in eine ecke
des internets in die ich noch nie
gegangen bin
bei musik und 22 angekommen dass seit
einiger zeit ein mensch sein unwesen auf
instagram treibt die man sonst
eigentlich nur aus dem fernsehen kennt
die rede ist von dieter bohlen sind sehr
bekannter musikproduzent und
fernsehmoderator unter anderem in
letzter zeit bekannt durch deutschland
sucht den superstar aber wie gesagt
dieter bohlen sachen instagram sehr
aktiven hat 735.000 abonnenten gesammelt
von bei den sachen die man da teilweise
sieht stellt sich eine frage die wir
heute beantworten werden ist dieter
bohlen verrückt geworden
und genau hier haben wir schon den kern
unserer beobachtung und zwar das
phänomen hashtag die tas tagesschau
hallo guten morgen bei die des tages
mensch leute schockerlebnis vor dem
morgen auf bob den baumeister ist kein
verletzten genau hier zeigt sich schon
der gemeinde plan von dieter bohlen er
ist immer mit einem breiten grinsen in
den videos anzutreffen zieht dadurch die
leute auf seine seite und redet dann
über dinge die nicht wirklich sinn
machen zum beispiel dass bob der
baumeister kein verlass ist liga für
mich
hallo bei die das tagesschau wir haben
jetzt 14 tage lang darauf gewartet heute
abend endlich 2015 wieder das
supertalent mit talenten ihr flippt aus
ich habe bob dem baumeister gefragt da
ist es schon wieder welche rolle spielt
bob der baumeister in diesem perfiden
konstrukt welche funktion hat diese
fiktive figur im kopf von dieter bohlen
steht bob der baumeister möglicherweise
in einer geheimsprache für was ganz
anderes was wir gar nicht verstehen ich
mache euch jetzt den wahnsinnigen
zaubertrick vor den habt ihr noch nie in
ihrem leben gesehen ich werde
transformieren sakko und gleich ist
ageto 12 versteht was ich meine mit
dieter bohlen verrückt geworden hallo
weil die das tagesschau hat ihnen geht
die heute morgen schick gemacht wollen
wir die leute weil ich und jetzt sind
wir kurz ta cco der lässigen war stehen
die flammen okay da sind wir die
komplexen von dieter bohlen das ist
scheinbar sakko welche rolle spielt der
komplize akku in diesem ganzen gebildet
wobei die das tagesschau ja leute ich
bin jetzt unterwegs
nach bohlens irgendwie und dem hat
natürlich auch ein start fahrer ihr der
christoph der der creo der kann fast
nichts gesehen als ich in den davor die
rübe gehalten haben die sowohl auf der
autobahn mehr oder weniger stellte wegs
und hält sein fahrer das smartphone
genauso vor die augen das ist man
eigentlich den fahrer kaum erkennt also
es kam was bringt und andererseits der
fahrer einfach überhaupt nicht sieht und
wahrscheinlich beide diesen vorfall
gerade so überlebt haben das hängt alles
klar
ihr könntet unterseite machen so ist
auch heute muss ich dann irgendwann
sagen es wird unzählige weise dafür dass
dieter bohlen verrückt geworden ist wir
sehen auch hier ist einfach nicht
angeschnallt das hat auch nichts die
fahren über die autobahn erhält seinem
fahrer des wahren vor die augen so dass
er nicht sieht und das aber nicht
angeschnallt ganz ganz von oben ich
glaube das sind etwa zehn meter und ich
zeige euch heute den gefährlichsten
stand den er je gesehen habe
das ist schon so eine aussage die nichts
gutes bedeutet aber wenn sie auf diesem
account getroffen wird denn sogar dieter
bohlen sagt dass er jetzt was ultra
gefährliches macht dann dann weiß ich
nicht was er vorhat will er die erde
explodieren lassen
gegen diese jacke tauschen
nur leute mein bester stand brauchen
noch mehr beweise leute hallo erstmal an
im hauptort regnet es wie gehört so was
gibt es also auch aber trotzdem die welt
ist doch schön die welt ist ein das ist
ja so eine sache auf diesem instrument
egal was passiert ist egal wo man gerade
in der rede ist und was um einen herum
passiert es ist immer alles top hallo zu
die das tagesschau es ist jetzt acht uhr
morgens in mallorca
ich bin gerade aufgestanden und ich muss
sagen es ist der schönste tag meines
lebens der fängt gut an es regnet
durchgehend und in strömen der himmel
ist verdeckt und halte man ja auch kein
bruder von zunahme ist überschwemmt aber
es kommt noch besser beim kaffee machen
habe ich mir gerade eben heißes wasser
über mein komplettes bein geschüttet und
verbrennungen dritten grades erlitten
ist das nicht wunderschön
möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen halo 3 die tagesschau
ihr werdet heute so manche überraschung
erleben
wir haben einen starken mann der qual
hat mit seinem ganzen kopf durch
eisblöcke her was rabatt.de schon jetzt
das wachstum weiter wo er natürlich
wieder in seiner klassischen stimmung
taucht auf masse auch wieso ein krokodil
was ich gerade an sven aufwand durch und
verkündete dass sie einen starken mann
haben der ballert und seinen kopf durch
eisblöcke haut warum für sie jetzt auch
so unangenehm ist zu schauen mich dass
gerade komplett
wir müssen und dann guckt euch die
spielweise den anderen bleiben die
gesund
also ich glaube er kann unsere
eingangsfrage ist dieter bohlen ford
gewordene beantworten mit ja ja ja aber
ganz ehrlich ich finde es nicht schlimm
das ist eigentlich schon unterhaltsam
wenn man für so was nennt übrig habt von
der räder dieses video leute kann jetzt
hier drüben noch einen für euch
persönlich vorgestellt das video vom
ankara abdecken von dem youtube sagt das
ist das video was ihr jetzt unbedingt
sehen muss deswegen eine clique drauf
schaut gerne weiter und bis zum nächsten
mal